Michael tannic hello going oh wait I can
resume hello Seve hello and in a mutt
okay so I died last time
that's the Kyla Network
20 who always crap on my back is there
anything I don't need
how do I know what's a mission thing and
what's not
I guess he's climbing oh okay I guess
it's all this stuff so do I need these
metals are they part of the mission I
don't think so because they're not
glowing what's that mmm screw it we'll
just try and take it all anyway
oh I got likes weapons restrictions
lifted why do they get like what was
that to pick up memory chips
be sure to submit them via the nearest
oh yeah so as I was slipping and sliding
down the mud today carrying my laptop on
my 2,000 pound camera I felt like I was
no more readers of Sam's bridges I
literally was like this is death
stranding in real life so it's quite
funny what do I do with this again this
is listen look outside alright yeah
stock-car crystals
no bridges up here Nicky where's your
bike
I don't think it I don't think is here
it's a lot stop it though how do i zoom
yeah that's see a bike around here check
the terminal for items oh you mean this
you didn't leave a bike in there is that
even possible
oh right okay
you left you should've left it outside
the terminal darn it
hey Luca now this game isn't scary don't
worry this is not Petey
although I did play PC last night
however my friends have something
they've never played Petey before and I
was like oh so I don't know if you guys
knew this but they have their Finn
people very clever people who have
remade Petey for the PC on it so we
played it back it's actually a really
good remake I think it's just called
playable teaser there are obviously some
bits in it it's not as pretty as the
original but that's pretty damn good
this oh yeah remember now
they like scan me don't
heads up Sam now for someone has eyes
look get to your destination ASAP if you
don't want to get caught okay so I died
oh can gotta go I died
[Music]
how that yeah I didn't see any of these
guys
Eva Eva oh my god so really I'm glad I
did that because I didn't see any of
that books I think I was like flowing
down a hill or something
oh yeah so this is when I died before
because of the beatings oh thanks tally
lives I actually did want to get into
acting a while back I used to be in the
theater when I was a kid I was a baby
June but I don't know I just don't even
know where to start on that and I'd like
making things behind listen to you then
I think I think that's why I like making
video games though because I feel like I
can put everything I like to do in one
place if that makes sense
so make a game I can do some voice
acting for it
I can do the music for it code for it I
can talk for it I can do everything that
I want to do it just it just kind of
makes sense to me
oh my god I should actually try and make
I should try and get my theater videos
would you guys want to see that in a
youtube video like little me and like me
just talking about how embarrassing is
let me know
oh yeah I think so I need to give the
chip back with something like George
Hansen right 99
George you need to get 100 likes oh
great
Lissa's mean what does this do I don't
know I'm helping the Georges structure
be upgraded
so what do I do with that nailh thing
that I picked up where do I leave I
won't tell you exactly but I live just
outside of London I guess I guess that's
not where I grew up they George is also
an NPC but bloody how when am I gonna
meet some actual people yeah I am I
picked up up thingy and I thought there
was something I could do with it
am I missing something guys
whatever what is this I don't know no
place it's one in here and then I can
attach this one to the suit there you go
now I have a little bit less to carry
should make life a little bit easier for
us on the approach Nuby cheese
if the name is green it's a natural
proxy that's good to know thank you for
that
well I think I've been able to tell
who's real people because it's like a
spittle one zero zero three
hold up okay so I'm going over there and
as soon as we get down here I'm gonna
half pint I'm gonna have to hide from
all the BTW interesting
how do I get down again get down on it
come on in you really want in so last
time I went around that way I'm gonna go
around that way this time I'm gonna go
around this way this is like the
scariest part
it's just kind of scary because you
can't really see like what you're what
you're avoiding so it's got some man
it's got some survival horror vibes to
it but you God so you follow this thing
whatever this thing is looking at you
don't go that way basically
ah they're on both sides of me and
there's one like right [ __ ] ahead of
me he's joking
Oh God about a gun
the Sun he can sense them and there are
people people with Doom's have different
my god
down
so fragile for instance she also has
dreams which is something that Sam has
but she can see the beauties and he can
only sense them even though I can kind
of see them sometimes but I guess it's
just representing his fencing over here
Oh make sure I don't fall through the
water that actually does help thank you
and I forgot to like it just to eat this
sit around I thought I was safe so you
can hold your breath as well which will
help them
hey Ethan lair
I can see them after scanning up ah
who said that Thank You noon but should
put those two
how's this game so far rewind rewind the
video and I tell you okay sorry I just
I'm I'm busy this is where I died last
time so I can't come to town I'm still
not very good at navigating my way
around bTW I let my housemate for this
and he's already beyond where I am but I
was out all day playing in the mud so
you know huh I felt like it must side oh
thank you oh it doesn't look so hard but
they can be restored now I can perform
the necessary maintenance at a
distribution center sorry though over
bring it I don't know Biggie's help I'm
off guys are the BT surrounds there was
that breakin bicycle I see it this is my
mission this is this is everything I've
ever wanted in Amos I can see it it's so
close I don't know if I can go that way
again
no I'm not risking it my crab Rachel
something down I think we're okay I
think we treat it done we made it guys
do you think you can make this yeah
maybe I should them put a ladder down
oh well it won't even know this is not
gonna help us
doo-doo-doo-doo she's gonna fall over I
shouldn't do this okay it's okay we'll
just find another way around
Oh am I gonna play the lastest part -
most probably I'm not gonna lie I didn't
play the first one when the strain on
your BP exceeds sustainable levels it
triggers the production of harmful
compounds and the body begins to attack
itself if your baby's not performing -
speck drop by your private room and see
if the incubator helps okay uh yeah so I
didn't play the first one and that's cuz
I used to have an xbox 360 and not a ps3
but I did watch other people play so I
know the story and everything in it I
wish I'd got to play that game for
myself because it was it was just great
the story the narrative I cried watching
so I don't know what state I would have
been in if I was actually playing so yes
I am definitely playing is that
someone's bike then or is it just is
this one here because this was gonna be
here should we have a look and see if
anyone actually left it for us
I can't use it you're so harsh
I'm ID please all the weapons will
remain mom until departure cargo verify
thank you
decontaminating suit rest advised
bestest advice
okay
hey Jamie I was out today doing some
video ring for a story and then I go I
nearly got lost in the woods and now I'm
really muddy but don't worry I didn't
film in the woods it just looked really
pretty okay so let's make our delivery
I haven't eaten I don't honey oh so this
was where I would do it because we've
got one memory chip so I'll do that
later then I guess once it gets hooked
up cool
Waystation took so me all about you
Sam bridges with the second expedition
began expanding the kyrobak work on his
long so what he's not out making
deliveries so what'd you bring us
let's see it talked about above and
beyond
Thanks must have had to pass through
Beattie territory to get here too didn't
you
legend send for the bridges legend I
can't get away with but yes I did Jamie
I got some really nice video of wall
textures
I actually got very into I found some
really painful walls
how did I do
I still cook I'll never get any points
for delivery time we just we just all
agreed on that okay never ever did every
volume though that was good
yes okay it's time
do you mind connecting us to the network
who is this I know what all these people
are supposed to be somewhat famous right
as always thanks for bringing more folks
into the UCA
mules and fern syndrome which bravery
isn't eyeful
cool yay now I can use those chips and
with those materials you brought for our
chiral printer we can produce supplies
for your ear as needed
about 10 things which is our way of
returning the favor a head west and keep
on doing what you do
I shall good the distro centers on the
network Sam do me a favor take your BP
to a private and connect them to the
incubator okay okay first of all so I'm
gonna share my memory chip data
whether well would you look at this
thank you so much Sam
you're welcome so I can look at it on my
top Thanks I thought I was gonna get a
little video or something
[Music]
well I can get messages from friends I
have no friends interviews you
transcripts of interviews
oh damn so I can really get into I like
this stuff because I remember I used to
play um the Batman Arkham games and one
thing I really liked about that night I
don't even know if the designers like
intended this when they made it like
this but I used to play the game and
like go and like find a bunch of staff
just have some fun I used to play it
like pretty much I was obsessed with the
Arkham games like every night and then
before I went to bed I would stop
playing but then I would read so if you
found secrets and stuff it would unlock
people's identities and like backstories
and stuff and then you could read about
it and so I would read the new ones I'd
found before going to bed so it's kind
of like I was reading a little story or
something before it a bit and that was
really nice so I would love to see more
games like that cuz I don't even think
that was intended because I know like in
Skyrim and stuff you can read little
books and stuff but it would be super
cool to see your progress in kind of
like a written maybe like a comic book
kind of style thing and then you have
something to read if you want to just
for those people who enjoy the backstory
and the narrative a bit more than just
the gameplay anyway yeah sorry I keep
like stretching I just it's actually not
comfortable to do this like I'm usually
just like back in bed like this so I've
been out just walking around all day
anyway I'll read this at some other
point but it's cooler that's their kind
of wish there was like an image with it
though I'm like a child
I need images let me picture books it's
where I read mangas no I do read no
thanks to mr. so what's this
ooh here's the pictures robot figurines
one of Japan's from yeah manufacturers
on plastic models each robot shares the
same basic frame architecture with
different external parts being attached
to create an individual map mechanoid
where's my chart they were
hey Ethan left please answer me by the
way I can't answer everybody by the way
I don't know what you said I didn't like
this round because it reminded the same
boring details from Phantom of pain fair
enough
stuff for everyone the bio Co figure is
a rare masterpiece based on one of Yoji
Shinkawa designs this is like actually
behind the development of the game I
like this
the fully realised world and kept
freaking story behind the frame and
series 1 it many dedicated fans cool is
that why their memory chips cuz I can
like stuff from the past that they've
done like in the real world that's cool
you got some tips as well holding down
buttons thank you
I think I know how to do that just about
um will go down and make sure the BB is
okay
hey Jonathan
hey so Ben tubi hey Alex for the end son
dead man you there little help okay Sam
remove the part and connect it to that
incubator
good a temporary excessive stress easily
addressed if we return it to its
mother's womb mother is this located in
the capital not City I see you bring
that of course he means still mother
correct a steal mother's womb
facilitates a connection between the
world of the dead and the baby and you
in turn connect yourself to a baby
granting you the ability to sense pities
materially sports were designed to
simulate the conditions inside a still
mother's womb
BB's need to believe their England at
all times to function properly however
we can only maintain this deception for
so long which is why we must
periodically update the environmental
data by synchronizing it with a still
mother via the chiral Network
weird idea Cosima yeah baby
thinking right now the board is
synchronizing with the steel mother in
capital not City and reconfiguring its
settings based on the latest data school
I guess that's why you feel nice
comforting your bb to the womb in this
manner will temporarily reduce its
stress levels that being where it
technically belongs of course
it looks happy now try adjusting
oxytocin Gossage out the calcaneus
should said is much lower than our
you should remember that babies are just
equipment try not to get attached each
one has been physically removed from its
steel mothers roof a process that
renders them unpredictable and prone to
failure no BP on record has remained in
service for over a year it may need to
be retired before this expedition is
over and then you saying there's no way
to keep my baby alive you must
understand there is still a great deal
we don't know of our babies as we expand
the chiral Network and recover more past
data perhaps we'll find our answers
oh right you asked me to look into why
the BTS might be reacting to your blood
I spoke with Hartman we should have your
results soon anyway you and your family
both exhausted
good night Sam good night cutie
why does he have to do that why does he
have to chain himself handcuffed himself
to the bed
London Bridge is falling
my boy Sam
can you see me how are things over there
still not under guard still not chained
up still can't leave I still understand
where they're allowing her to talk to me
what if you can keep making connections
if you can get to me
we can go back east back home
thank you
I mean that it's bad there are fewer and
fewer people in the cities these days
no one's having children anymore but
humans aren't made for living alone
they're supposed to come together so
relatable and differ we as a people
can't do that if we can't recognize the
state of the world right now and well
we're just kind of like Richard slide I
like stinking it's not gelling in there
it's not fun it's like it's also kind of
foolish they're still around there's no
escaping it but at least we'll have hope
I'll be waiting Sam
waiting for you
come and find me delivery man plays
hide-and-seek
this is hard since you're awake it might
be in depression up to that end why not
take a shower is that a hint do it's not
good for the body and soul and also my
research as it happens oh yeah sound
winking at me did you guys see did
anyone see my Instagram video yeah so
I'm dead party oh wait you play now what
do you want to do wash your face yeah
sure
what is why don't you do that what it's
like what is that why are you choking
yourself I don't know somebody do these
things all right
nice house
whoa
we have some more figures do we sure we
were your Legos those ones are cool I
really like the the PT ones I actually
think that idea cuz she really should
like release some Lego Lego men beauties
I want them
patrol you'd be like that one well done
well prior to you how do I get out okay
let's have a shower
so stop
study other people with Doom's take this
out forbid you should the opportunity
arise try using it on a PT I'm curious
to see how they react okay who knows it
may even prove beneficial to you there
was an old research paper detailing the
effects of orderly fluids from
individuals like cars on BTS
it is only by recovering these materials
that we can unearth the knowledge of the
past not just a death stranding but also
the mystery of your body's unique
properties and even our dooms affliction
there may well be hope to humanity Sam I
have no interest in rebuilding America I
want to recover the past oh it's almost
time after you make your connections and
nothing happens then what I said then
what
Sam sorry to bother you while you're
taking a break but I figured you know
maybe it'll help you read some mail
we received a number of messages
addressed to you I'm not taking a look
myself but I gather they're mostly from
your clients you should see if they
contain any useful information may I
just be accessed by your cufflinks as
well as the terminal your private room
there's something else I'd like to share
with you know with the Cairo network we
now have the power to reclaim our past
data once thought lost forever from
every corner of America can be pieced
back together from fragmented records
our archives are still a work in
progress of course but as we expand the
network and integrate more weigh
stations and cities we'll be able to
recover more and more information such
as the previous expeditions logs and
reports everything they sent back was
lost when central not City was destroyed
we've managed to restore some already in
fact you can access them from a private
room terminal or your cuff links by
selecting archives might make for
interesting reading
well
Oh what's up with you are you okay
my Carpinelli
he's not happy bunny okay so let's read
our mail um thanks just mean there's
potatoes everyone uh probably I can't
see my head's in the way appreciates you
I'm afraid I've got some bad news bike
you saw outside battery's dead
no you have to give us some juice if you
want to use it
oma once though also charges should kick
in after I don't know what that says
sorry if I got you like excited or
something probably um got your hopes of
it that's it only need to do it once
you'll have to give us some juice it
okay so I don't you have to do it once
and I got some more bad news for you too
you see different facilities have to
work together showing materials so
everyone gets what they need and to make
sure that everything that's produced
gets put to proper use that's why guys
like us own bullet without porters the
whole system falls apart the whole world
even anyway this is guy George V on
button they Don over at the weigh
station he used to be reliable water but
lately it's like pulling teeth getting
him to make even the simplest delivery
keeps bitching about being scared not
having enough oxy or whatever voicing
excuse even when he does agree to make
it run he's liable to lose half the load
so yeah that's why we're a bit short on
materials at the moment I'm sure you'll
soon help us put right so that okay okay
so they want more materials and the bike
these shoes if I have anything sound the
man our Savior things are looking up
everything feels better we're all
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed I
systemness ill change anyone's tune
he'll when we first got thought about
okay so they're all happy when central
went up I tell
myself this was it America's done
everyone go away on it everyone was
feeling it too and the mood was just
bleak and when you waltzed on in and
then you once done it I know what you're
thinking at first I thought it was just
the oxytocin - but that's not it not all
of it anyway you gave us the glimmer of
hope we need it by bringing us into the
Cairo Network we're back in the game we
think you're putting up signs again
which towers - before long we'll be
opening up new delivery routes mark my
words it's scary out there though all
the oaks in the world won't help us deal
with me all let alone be teased we shoot
ourselves every time we catch sight of
one and end up dropping half our
equipment I wanna see a part of me is
still a little worried that we won't be
able to keep it up and that's why we
need you Sam you're not scared of
anything bright get yourselves done so
everyone's like we need you we can't do
this you are the Saviour of the world
cool no pressure great Sam we've
received a distress call from the distro
center staff check the order on the
delivery term annoy soon as you're ready
okay
how you doing baby are you doing oh wait
I'm supposed to sue them
I want to suit the baby hey sharks fan I
can read the comments yes can you say
thank you to me you're supposed to give
people thank you I can't see every
comment so I don't know what you said I
think the babies beanie looks happy
and he okay I remember I watched this
one video and you were like playing with
baby but then something happened and you
like had a nightmare I wasn't thinking
then you broke up I want that to happen
cuz it looks so cool the video loads he
just stops reacting to you hey Carlos
back we are back we are
we don't have any weapons Brisco believe
ourselves drinks and monsters can we get
our stamina up anymore maybe hey Fred
enjoying the game
yeah it's honestly so different and I
really I like the idea behind it it's
such a way that comes up with music I
like the idea behind it I like how it
has practical meaning I like how it's
extremely unique and the controls just
the controlling firm is very different
to anything that I used to but I do
understand why it it might be a little
bit boring to watch so I'm sorry if
anyone gets bored I mean you don't have
to be nervous
maybe she's of water on the baby
I skipped point but I think it's
supposed to look like that oh dear
he gets so into those monster drinks oh
can have more stamina yeah
you did kind of wish that I could like
to skip that animation because obviously
you want to do it until your summoner
gets up to the fall but then you have to
watch him drink every single one you see
I guess I'll be your different no I
think it's the same animation every time
is that the the fullest yeah drink one
more and then I think not a part of me I
can get it oh my gosh Nikki's playing
the game and you're outside by the bike
is gonna be cooling for it if I went
outside I could see you that's not how
it works in this game but it would be
cool let's put our Sunny's on my Maria
Pizza keep on drinking - his heart fails
now that would be realistic Aladdin a
darlin oh my god I'm so sorry
he looks a bit silly with those own not
gonna lie but you know what he likes
them you know so Who am I to judge cares
good
there's a woman in the man's been
nothing but like me
I was Sam I just think I like this the
whole time
I'll be disconnecting reconnecting to
find out the whole survive managing your
BB stress levels and reducing the risk
about to talk Semak attacks there are a
few things you can do if your BB starts
showing signs of distress such as such
as take a moment to look after it seems
freedom rocket that sort of thing yeah
how's it doing here uh before I answer
that something wrong when I hook up my
BB I see things what kind of things like
a face someone I don't know calling to
me there's this room to with other
people talking but I can't make out the
words you're mistaking the VP's memories
for your own their false flashbacks
nothing more let me explain a BB is
harvested from its steel mother and
around 28 weeks and placed in a pot to
be clear this is before it's even born
the procedure holds its development but
even at 28 weeks its sensory systems
have matured enough to process external
stimuli it is more than capable of
encoding this information into memories
which can bleed into yours via your
connection so who is the man I saw
someone from the medical team maybe or a
BB technician does it matter the baby
has been in circulation for a while now
it's the dyes been handled by a lot of
people should I know which one made an
impression because you're the expert
no one's an expert secret
they're your quintessential black boxes
we may use them but we don't truly
understand them believe me I've been
trying to learn more but almost all of
the old records are gone if I find
anything out I'll tell you all right
depends on her No
okay so I'm gonna go your heads if I
know what I'm doing next
well you're arresting a trend some
network Diagnostics there really are
monitoring and holographic systems are
not unfortunately our printer is offline
I know I know after all the trouble you
went through to bring us those materials
this one's on us we ordered a part while
back but it never arrived the printer
needs it to communicate with the keidel
member mules must have snatched it
thought that Porter enroute or something
if I'm right they'll have taken it to
their drop site which is smack dab in
the middle of their territory don't
suppose you'd be up for stealing us our
property back you can't think of anyone
more qualified than you of course I
would love to deliver
I gotta get the cow juice those are
Mama's added a watchtower schematic to
your PCC if you don't have it on you
consider fabricating what never know
when you'll need to recall in an area
okay my knees big one then
oh yeah I got that grenade stuff I've
got to in here
sure take that yeah I probably should
touch it - this suit
[Music]
what they look what is this presence
what is that don't know yeah cuz I don't
already know what it is
okay so I have one ladder grenade to
pcc's to climbing anchors maybe I should
make another ladder press the touchpad
venire to like okie dokie Nikki you
still at the beginning it feels like it
but I think I played about three hours
of this game now
[Music]
wait can I make stuff all right
okay Candide idea why I need to what
does this mean night
me
Vonk
where's Varga meeting what is the log
okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna be fine food wasn't
churning I'm gonna leave a happy sign
it works baby yeah
on someone else that's the happy baby TV
lovers Christ what is this all these
come from
it's one of these you're Nikki you sit
and look by the flight when I go out
what CI restrictions lifted this isn't
your name though
maybe is
hey Danielle oh you're a little bit late
but don't worry you're here and that's
the main thing
okay so I need to recharge this wait so
what the backup fuel is full of like
okay
oh my god
I need to go
I guess looks like it
okay let's go what you taught to fly for
the KCC welcome for the bridges what
these restrictions lifted
just that work
No
it doesn't work Nikki oh right okay I
can't let's do it this Saturday
fair enough well thanks for trying to
let me know anyway uh I'm gonna put them
back on my say alright well is it logic
I was just holding them on my best okay
let's go
beginning Stan Stan and bridges ID
verifying ID clear weapons detected all
weapons will be locked until the punch
all clear welcome Santa morta bridges
non leaving
weapons restrictions lifted call it a
rule or habit but most mules almost
always bring stolen shipments home with
them
find the postbox steal back the cargo as
simple as that
but be careful these guys are armed if
this goes sideways be ready to fight
uh-oh I don't have any weapons how much
specified
okay just press square alright what's
this you want
I mean I have a robot I needed it is it
you just woke up at this you guys may be
retiring at law
this here's a bro
thank you for remember Sam before you
approach the mule drop site we recommend
you use a watch tower to confirm the
location of the postbox campaigning our
cargo
you'll drop sites are rarely deserted so
remaining undetected
is key slowly to minimize noise
that's it right
Wow look it's cover from the rain well
that's nice thanks for letting me know
and a lot of people's dropped stuff but
I think the last like Carrie now the
better there is a lover here though
shall be handy boy
igneel spot you can dodge our attacks by
pressing L 2 R 2 and X thank you hit it
with the lava that's a good idea
different it's easy to kill them is it
Turkey okay well her clay won't have to
come to that but sorry to say when I
talk to you guys as I answer it's my
favorite show any of your names I feel
so guilty every time okay
I think it will come to that No
all right
there we go again
about it it's a good idea like am I
gonna go okay I'm going down with this
well since the birth
see the grass here yeah okay I'm
carrying that way
trying to figure out they'll be in that
but I need to get oh you know I played
Metal Gear Solid once and I was very bad
at the stealth aspect which does not
give me much hope for how well I will do
at stealth yeah where the bloody hell
are all the C's ball is that a person
yep
what to do they're coming to get you go
here don't I
can I make him move
like I do anyway
so anyone else is it's just that guy
it's on him what do I do I don't want to
hurt him I want a different option I
want a different option how does he not
hear that I just did that
use the Strand what what's round okay
what don't I need what can I put in
there and I picked up something didn't I
Oh looks like I need everything I picked
up okay
well o other me your boots better than
my boots bridges boots level 10.4 what
about the mule boots they're 0.5 no
better
okay somebody told us
I can't attach it to my suit too big I
can't touch this into my suit
yeah
I got it all
sweetie I'm off
thanks violence is not the answer guys
but nabooru
I know they wanted some more materials
but I've already got one material thing
anyway so I think we're fine snake would
be so proud of you
mm-hmm Thanks Thanks
he must have a lot of back pain do yeah
what did you see at CIA I don't mention
it cause I think there was talking
carry-on but when he went and have a
shower there I was oh my god people
before his people here his people his
people his people he had nice people
well I'm gonna go to the cave I'm gonna
back this way
oh but yes when he was up in your shower
you could see like the chafing on his
shoulders it's pretty cool cuz I'm
pretty sure they went there before I'm
gonna use this broke again to back up
so are the difference that I see are
they always mine or they are the players
as well I think that is mine
what time you got this yeah that's my
man
Sam the man he can't do it
so again oh this honesty is such a great
well place for a very thankful for this
rope
whoof all right forgot about my shifting
weight
try not to fall down v now
Oh
Nietzsche steps
Hey ah what name
oh nice that's right helpful thank you
so much wait did I come up this way
yeah let's take it
hey slender's elder bees
mewls yeah addicts chasing a car go hi
Shane we got a deal with their [ __ ]
at all back in the day eh I did
everything deliveries were handled by
unmanned vehicles and drones it was
revolutionary
damn near singularity no reason for it
not to take off but it people didn't
like you that we took the human element
out of the service industry so do some
consideration put it back in mate jobs
no one really needed and gave them the
folks who couldn't live without them and
from there it's Noble now we've got
copse of cargo chasing crazy to get off
on hijacking the shipments jackals
always on the lookout for the exporter
make sure you're not here
cool apparently the environments change
later on I'm excited to see more very
issues of environment because I do agree
with nervous Jay like at the moment is
everything seems a little bit samey but
I have been in the same place basically
I haven't really moved much so I'm
pretty excited to see what destinations
and what environments I can get I know
that's hot but I can like things and Hot
Springs route stuff master
his Fitbit must be going crazy how yes
I want to rock my baby baby baby
Porter bridges
got your stuff and I didn't even kill
anyone
yeah time to get that chiral printer in
working order sorry but she's there so
much trouble but trust me it'll be worth
it because again pike
excellent the unit doesn't have a
scratch on it I know never doubted you'd
come through for us Sam
now your shoes holding up uncle imagine
conditions being what they are out there
well I just changed them yeah well shoes
falling apart while you're on the job
Gary I'm like that and it's only a
matter of time before you injure
yourself I've arranged for boots to be
added to your supplies bridges standard
issue so they ought to fit you fine
you should always carry an extra pair
but if you forget or run into trouble
you can fabricate another by a terminal
good work Sam it seems your connection
level is increasing and the connection
level increases larger quantities of
resources will be made available to you
at our facilities
hologram data to use the state of gain
access to a level two or higher
structure and select Customize
disruption interesting more structures
can be built the amount of material some
can use the district distribution center
has been increased okay so now I can
like build my bridges and stuff up
bridges my ladders and stuff
congratulations sir I understand you now
have access to a chiral printer an
extraordinarily versatile device that
can only function because it's manner in
which our network utilizes the beach
enabling us to transfer massive volumes
of data instantaneously since other
normal circumstances such transfers
would take hours not days some have
speculated that the chiral network might
s's be a time machine that it is
transmitting data into the past suffice
it to say we have yet to fully grasp on
the mental nature
and the beach we have come to revival
what Mike Mike and our relationship with
into battle primitive man's fine is it
useful quite is it dangerous undeniably
sir
nevertheless we have decided that the
reward outweighs the risk furthermore as
the VG's are linked to the beach it
stands to reason and further study and
experimentation could be a considerable
benefit the saying that it be said
regarding you of course rest assured I
will keep you apprised please acts as a
delivery terminal for further
information
I just wanna ride the bike please I
guess now I have to do this one
okay so I have new shoes tomorrow yes
wait which she's better I think the new
ones cuz they're 0.5 and this is 0.4 and
I guess 0.5 is better than they prefer
so I'll just put them on and I will put
these in this storage
I want I need to get this one back as
well okay that thing you're holding is a
crystal collector now as the name
suggests oh when I was trying to collect
this Christie's earlier wouldn't that
mean cuz I didn't have the right thing
this is it chiral crystals appeared gold
to the naked eye and frequently found
formations resembling human Hamlin's
surrounding rocks tend to float near
feet above the ground
and they're most commonly found in areas
with high precipitation got all that
rain floating rocks golden Halperin's
that's my vector for these three things
and you'll find the crystals if you've
been this oh I know I know you don't
well let me give back this card
cool I'm just gonna try to evoke Phoebe
party it was what did you say L 1 and L
1 PI think Phoebe's okay so I don't
think you'll do anything that's anyway
I'm gonna go right now because I need to
make a dinner and then get ready for bed
and stuff but thank you so much for
spending a bit of time with me tonight
des données odd you love it yes it is
odd yes I love it
that's what prints the description cuz
it's it's difficult to write sentences
on a Playstation
but yeah please make sure that if you
enjoyed this and you want to know what
I'm streaming next just make sure that
you subscribe with that Bell you'll get
an application or just make sure that
you follow me on Twitter on the discord
chat and I will let you guys know when
I'm gonna be streaming next I will just
give you guys a little invite I guess
because why not
oops
[Music]
never expire
maybe gay
if anyone uses discord you can come into
our little our little group but yeah so
if you want to see more of this do let
me know and I will keep one streaming it
for you whenever I want to play it again
which will probably be very soon so
thanks again for joining me
have a lovely evening more to see sounds
gonna chill and I'm gonna chill too so
maybe you should also chill yep see you
next time goodbye